est le premier surpris a été le
directeur lui-même de la radio fm de
paris nrj cette radio avec cinq de ses
consoeurs est en conflit avec la haute
autorité de l'audiovisuel qui lui
reprochent d'avoir des émetteurs trop
puissant et de brouiller la bande fm que
ce soit pour les aéroports ou les
pompiers nrj avait été suspendu
aujourd'hui pour 30 jours
la radio avait appelé ses auditeurs des
jeunes à descendre dans la rue
et surprise ce ne sont pas les 5 ou 6000
manifestants attendus qui ont défilé
dans paris mais 30000 selon la police
200 mille selon les organisateurs
en tout cas une manifestation qui
démontre amplement le poids des radios
fm malgré les conflits du moment
expliqué par la présidente de la haute
autorité
nichèle quotas
faut se mettre en conformité sinon avec
la loi au sens strict du terme
au moins avec la haute autorité il ya
des règles du jeu on peut pas jouer sur
la touche tout le temps et à 12 100
radios dans la france est à 23
fréquences sur paris il est évident que
chacune d'entre elle veut être mieux
entendu ça fait partie de la course
normale mais c'est une course à la
puissance que nous voulons que nous
voulons entravé et elle nous voulons
mettre un terme parce que cette course à
la puissance de bord et sans enfant la
manifestation était à peine terminée
qu'on apprenait que les dirigeants du
nrj allait rencontrer les responsables
de tdf dès lundi pour étudier les
modalités d'une diffusion acceptable la
vie